but i met you at jfl in montreal yeah
and you were tooling around montreal
with your friend you're friends with the
guy that killed bin laden rob o'neil
yeah yeah me and robert buddies yeah how
are you friends with the guy who killed
bin laden okay so what's that called six
what was he secret uh sealed team six
sealed team six yes i thought it was a
secret did they come out and say who
they were
i didn't even know that he got in
trouble yeah rob tweets about it there's
no problem
and he wrote a book didn't he get in
trouble with the uh there's a lot of
okay they said there's some members of
the seal team that don't like him but he
had a couple of bodyguards that were
other members of the seal team as well
so
you know i i don't know about that but
but um rob i met rob at a party okay so
this is i don't know if rob even knows
this story but we had a mutual friend
and he was a photographer and he was
taking photos and he said uh he was
trying to make him loosen up for the
shots he said what bands you into what
this you didn't do what what comedy are
you into maybe we can listen to some
comedy while we're doing the [ __ ] he
goes i like jim jefferies and he goes
i'm friends with jim jeffries and he's
like oh can i meet him and so this guy
rings me up and goes the guy who shot
bin laden
wants to meet you right how do you say
no yeah and i went i went uh tell him
i've got a barbecue
this sunday i didn't have a [ __ ]
barbecue so i manufactured a party
this guy meet the guy who killed bin
laden barbecue yeah yeah yeah
so i i matter of fact and we've been
friends ever since but i i manufactured
this barbecue and i i rang up a few
different friends of mine to say look
the guy who met shop bin laden who do
you call to bring to uh the bin laden
killer there was the only other famous
person that was there was rhys darby
from you know our flag means death and
flight of the conchords and he played
marion yeah yeah yeah yeah i know i
still love him
he's really funny yeah so i i rang up
rhys and i said the guy shot bin laden's
coming over and so him and his wife came
over and a few other friends like that
and uh
so so rob and two other seal team guys
the big blokes sort of tattoos and all
that type of stuff
and uh i i sort of got told he's the
red-headed guy out of the group so there
was one red-headed blake and and and i
went up to him and i i told everybody i
said the guy shot bin laden's coming
you're not meant to mention it no one
knows but he's going to be here but
don't say anything like this right it's
supposed to be like undercover yeah yeah
yeah well i didn't know that he told
people right at a barbecue where you're
inviting the guy who shot bin laden what
do you do you barbecue you have super
suckers yeah yeah stuff like that
and so so i put the sun in the
bulletproof vest you know he was about
two at the time yeah anyway so
so uh so i went up to him and i went uh
g'day rob i said look no one else at the
party knows uh but i've been told and i
just want to thank you for what you've
done for the country and
it's just really great to meet you mate
and he said what that i shot bin laden
loud enough for everyone to hear
and then and then it was over the
beginning of the night it was like this
i knew that day i was going to die and
then i thought to myself i said goodbye
to my daughters and i went to the war
and we got in the helicopter and then
and then later on in the night it was
just like this ah it's just like
shooting a deer in butte montana
did he give you the details yeah yeah he
said walked up and and there was one bit
where he said to me he goes i was
barbecuing i heard the story about four
times that night i was drunk off to the
side barbie and and one of the girls
like the women were all just sitting
around just fascinated and one of he
goes then i saw the whites of bin
laden's eyes right
and he goes and then he said uh and then
one of the girls went did you say
anything and he goes i didn't actually
but i wanted to say yahtzee which is
like a thing in their world where they
go yahtzee before they shoot i don't i
don't know i think it's just a board
game yeah yeah i think and i was a
barbecuing up to the side no this is one
of these terrible hero stories and then
i said something funny uh i was up to
the side and i said i said ah that's
stupid and he goes oh yeah what would
have you said i said
i would have said where have you been
laden there we go
now i think as rob does motivational
talks and stuff like that he says that
he told me that he says that he says
that now sometimes in some of the
speeches just for a life you're stealing
your material i gave it to you
how am i gonna use it so that
and you're not going to argue with the
guy that shot it's a great story for a
podcast we did it we did the we did a
thing on um on the on the jim jeffery
show we did it we did a thing where i
interviewed him and we went out and we
shot some guns and uh we we got out this
sniper rifles with bullets you know big
three inch bullets or whatever they had
large bullets right i'm not a gun guy
and we lined up two watermelons off in
the distance with these sniper rifles
that can shoot like miles you know
and uh just for a finishing shot we were
both going to blow up a watermelon i hit
mine he missed his
and really yeah and people think that we
obviously staged it that way or what but
no i hit mine he missed this are you
sure he wasn't just doing that he was
[ __ ] but he's not a sniper
he'd been one he was doing that stuff
where he was like ah the bloody gauge
it's like when a golfer picks up someone
else's clubs this is the wrong shot yeah
but bin laden was when he shot in london
but no no it's like a foot and a half
yeah yeah he was just in the room he was
just in the room just wow so you're a
better shot than well in that one
instance i was i assume if we did it
over a bigger span you're like seal team
three we went over a bigger set yeah
sealed team three the catering
[Music]